messieurs bonjour
non je ne dis pas mesdames c'est un gain
de temps et messieurs ça fait plus
professionnel en plus si on dit madame
est ce qu'on doit dire mais loisel il ya
des femmes qui sont pas mariés 1
c'est important que je le sache des
hommes non mariés
non ça aucune importance en plus bon
mais oiseaux ça fait quand même un peu
vieux jeu non donc voila moi je dis
juste bonjour messieurs et c'est très
bien comme ça non pourquoi pas gauche et
droite y est bonjour je classe aussi les
genres deux catégories ça paraît bien
non ah mince les ambidextre ou alors
juste bonjour
mais après tout est ce que c'est
vraiment capital de souligner le genre
des personnes qu'on salue pourquoi est
ce que notre éducation nous a appris que
c'est plus poli
bonjour monsieur bonjour madame c'est un
automatisme
on le dit comme ça sans réfléchir sans
réfléchir
bon c'est marrant parce que moi quand
j'arrive dans un commerce je vois bien
que les gens sont obligés de réfléchir
avec mon apparence beaucoup de gens se
retrouvent en difficulté et donc j'ai
régulièrement le droit à des bonjour
madame bonjour mon petit bonheur voir
bonjour messieurs dames quand je suis
tout seul rappelle j'ai 28 ans et je
suis une seule personne bon cette
hésitation quand on dit bonjour et
toujours accompagnée d'un malaise
palpable chez la personne en face de moi
elle attend une réponse ça semble
indispensable pour la suite de notre
interaction monsieur ou madame homme ou
femme
la réponse pour moi c'est monsieur mais
ce n'est ni homme ni femme
je m'explique monsieur c'est l'interface
social que j'utilise ça traduit
l'expression de mon genre j'ai un prénom
masculin on parle de moi au masculin
exemple antonin il est petit mais
costaud revanche on peut souvent la
question mais tu es un homme
une femme est bien la meilleure réponse
que j'ai trouvé c'est non c'est à dire
que mon identité de genre se situe en
dehors de ces deux cases hommes femmes
ont dit que mon genre eh non billère ce
qui somme toute est assez amusant parce
que je suis informaticien donc le
binaire ça me fait pourtant pas peur la
société occidentale
elle aime la binarité ça la rassure
alors bien souvent elle m'a forcé à
choisir soit hommes soient femmes dans
les formulaires à la question de sexe
quand je peux je ne coche
aucune des deux cases ou bien je coche
les deux mais le petit malin qui fait
sens les sondages c'est moi et puis bon
quand je n'ai vraiment pas le choix je
coche hommes parce que c'est ce qu'il ya
de plus proche de mon identité
enfin le formulaire pourquoi est-ce
qu'on veut vraiment savoir si je suis un
homme quand on étudie ma consommation de
café ou quand je fais ma carte de
bibliothèque
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne me demande
jamais si j'ai les cheveux lisses ou
crépus ou si je préfère star trac ou
star wars
pourquoi toujours vouloir à tout prix
distinguer les hommes et les femmes dans
les formulaires et oui je sais sans
doute que quelque part dans un bureau au
marketing
il ya quelqu'un qui essaie de nous
vendre des produits mais essentielles
comme du dentifrice pour hommes ou des
stylos à bille pour femmes
non mais ça existe existe vraiment enfin
vous me direz infâme c'est comme la base
la société fonctionne comme ça tiens
d'ailleurs on a tous un numéro de
sécurité sociale qui commence par un on
pardonne à spa bon bah vous saviez qu'il
y avait aussi des numéros provisoire en
7 et en 8es qu'avant il y avait les
trois des quatre des cinq des six sadate
de vichy iii et iv c'était pour les
algériens et les colonisés 5 et 6 pour
les juifs français
eh oui placer les gens ça ne coule pas
de source
ça choisi ses politiques d'ailleurs
entre le 1 et le 2
ce ne sont pas les femmes qui ont elles
un oui mais le 1 et le 2 sur la carte
vitale c'est important pour envoyer aux
femmes des invitations au dépistage du
cancer du col de l'utérus n'est ce pas
mais ce qu'on veut est ce que c'est
vraiment envoyer ses invitations aux
femmes aux personnes qui ont un utérus
certaines femmes n'ont pas ou plus
d'utérus certaines personnes ne sont pas
des femmes et ont insulté russe ouais
pendant invitation dépistage on n'est
pas sorti de l'auberge
bah oui mais la réalité est complexe en
plaques est un modèle binard dessus
n'efface pas cette complexité
salam à ce que seulement alors ce
système 2 1 et 2 devant nous le prendre
comme un outil ou comme une règle
immuable
bon bah moi ça m'arrangerait que ce soit
pas venu à blanc parce que mon numéro de
sécurité sociale il commence par un peu
refait depuis le début avant même ma
naissance
mes parents ont été confrontés à la
question alors vous attendez quoi et 20
un bébé interdite c'est un raptor voilà
bon bien sûr ce que la question
sous-entend c est ce que ce sera un bébé
mâle ou un bébé femelle
qu'est ce que ça nous apporte de
toujours vouloir poser cette question
qu'est-ce que ça va changer dans notre
comportement face à ce foetus ou est ce
nouveau né c'est pour décider si le
cadeau de naissance ce sera un tube de
dentifrice forum ou un stylo bille pour
femmes
voilà donc en gros comme tous les autres
bébés j'étais pas encore né et que les
gens faisaient déjà des tonnes de
projection chambre à la naissance
un médecin a examiné mon entregent et a
déclaré c'est une femelle pas besoin
d'être médecin pour ça en est pourtant
personne n'a songé à analyser les
chromosomes sexuels xx x y ou une autre
formule personne n'a non plus étudié mes
organes internes découvert combien des
testicules internes un utérus
personne ne se dit donc lui tient cet
enfant il faut qu'on mesure c'est
hormonaux mais tout au long de sa
croissance
en fait le sexe est déterminé par une
foule de critères
et pourtant à ma naissance aux mains
coup d'oeil
un médecin a déclaré c'est une femelle
collègues professionnels 100% sur 0 12
tomes bon en fait mes organes génitaux
externes rentrait tout simplement dans
les normes que la médecine a fixé parce
que ces normes
elles ont été fixées
par des gens c'est quoi la taille
réglementaire d'un pénis ou d'un
clitoris
c'est quoi une vulve normal la nature
elle elle ne s'embête pas à lire le
manuel de médecine donc bien plus aux
banques en imaginant des gens naissent
avec des organes génitaux externes qui
ne rentrent pas dans les normes que la
médecine a fixé ce sont des personnes
intersexe alors on fait quoi de ces
personnes là on les met dans laquelle de
nos deux cases
en france on a la solution
l'habitude est d'opérer ses nouveau nés
qui n'ont rien demandé pour les réparer
chirurgicalement
en fait les rendre conformes à la case
qu'on a choisi à leur place donc oui en
france des médecins blanc pratique aussi
d excision en toute légalité
je ne sais pas pour vous mais moi quand
même un système avec des cases
quand ça mène à utiliser les enfants ça
me pose question
pas vous ce qui s'est passé ce qui en
fait je me suis retrouvé dictée à la à
la naissance à l'internet et femelles
donc 100% sur 1,0 doute hélas il ya eu
un raccourci mais complètement délirant
les gens ont commencé à raconter que
j'étais une fille
oui alors oui ce qu'ils ont imaginé ça
j'en sais rien vous étiez à la réunion
s'était décidée parce que moi j'ai pété
invités du coup j'aimerais au moins
récupérer les documents de travail
ouais bon pis voilà donc bon bah du coup
la rumeur s'est répandue j'étais une
fille comme je savais pas encore
emballés en vue que je venais d'être
impossible de démentir donc mes parents
ont vraiment cru que j'étais une fille
et puis bah ils m'ont colle un prénom de
fille et résultat on a créé une identité
administratif féminines 1 f sur un
carnet l'entité 1,2 à la sécu un voile a
tamponné merci vers mes trois ans j'ai
du coup mais la grosse bourde qui avait
été fait en jettent rosé rien dire parce
que comme ça me semblait hallucinant que
tous ces adultes et puis se tromper
comme ça va quand même les adultes c'est
des gens qui savent compter jusqu'à plus
que mille bien plus tard j'ai découvert
que d'autres personnes avaient subi les
mêmes erreurs de la part d'autres
adultes qu'ils savaient eux aussi compté
jusqu'à plus que 1000 et qu'en fait en
europe
il semblerait que
la plupart des adultes considèrent que
une fille efforts semaine femelle est
donc un garçon est forcément un mal
alors oui la plupart du temps ça marche
ça marche pour les gens qu'on dit si
genre leur genre hommes femmes
correspond à ce à quoi on s'attend
d'après leur sexe mâle femelle
statistiquement c'est un bon nombre
d'entre vous un voilà vous allez pouvoir
rentrer à la maison en sachant enfin que
vous êtes une personne si genre et puis
il ya des personnes pour qui ce
raisonnement automatique mal garçons
femelle fille ne fonctionne pas ce sont
des personnes transgenres
c'est mon cas et on est plein et on est
partout et non on n'est pas contagieux
ou alors être une personne transgenre
m'offre un atout considérable dans la
vie celui de subir des questions
indiscrètes de la part de n'importe qui
à n'importe quel moment
ce que j'aimerais mois plus tôt c'est
que les gens applique une règle toute
simple que j'ai appelé la règle de la
boulange et tu t'apprêtes à me poser une
question est ce que ce serait déplacé de
faire de même dans une boulangerie
si oui tu tapes stien exemple une
question sur mes organes génitaux
oui bonjour je voudrais une baguette
aussi savoir si vous avez un vagin
donc tu tapes siens et non tu ne peux
pas non plus me palper pour satisfaire
tes curiosité
autre aspect cocasse de ma vie de
personnes transgenres mais papiers
d'identité ne traduisent pas mon
identité
donc si je l'échangé actuellement en
france changer le f1 aime changer mon
prénom de naissance par mon vrai prénom
antonin je dois attaquer l'état dans un
tribunal de grande instance où la
plupart des juges vont demander un
papier de psychiatres attestant que je
souffre d'une maladie mentale
oui comment vous avant avec
l'homosexualité est la preuve que j'ai
été stérilisés oui comme en fait que les
animaux chez le vétérinaire et donc à
cause de ses papiers
ma vie quotidienne et plein de petites
complications comme par exemple recevoir
mon courrier à deux prénoms différents
sur ma boîte aux lettres je n'ai mis que
mon nom de famille si je mets mes deux
prénoms bon tout un immeuble de rekem
assez vite comprendre que je
ma soeur voilà question respect de la
vie privée moyens au téléphone je me
retrouve aussi régulièrement à devoir
jouer le rôle de ma propre épouse ou de
mon propre fils c'est un peu perturbant
mais bien trop souvent cette incongruité
administrative est beaucoup plus dur à
vivre c'est quand je paye par chèque et
qu'on m'accuse d'avoir volé le chéquier
c'est au bureau de vote
quand les assesseurs crie mon prénom de
naissance que plusieurs paires d'yeux me
dévisage lexus questions vont plus vers
ça je connais trop de personnes trans
gens qui ont arrêté d'aller voter
c'est aussi quand le contrôleur dans le
train m'accuse à vous d'avoir fraudé me
tutoie les ma carte d'identité à tout le
wagon que je bafouille des explications
honteuse et qu'ensuite j'ai peur pour ma
sécurité parce qu'un mec m'a regardé
méchamment et que j'ai trop d'amis à qui
on a cassé la gueule pour ne pas y
penser c'est chaque guichet chaque
papier administratif à fournir et puis
c'est aussi quand les étudiants de
médecine apprennent encore aujourd'hui
que comme toutes les personnes
transgenres je suis un malade mental de
l'amade manteau on les écoute pas en les
stérilisent plutôt finalement finalement
tout ça parce que des adultes qui savent
compter jusqu'à plus qu ils sont
enfermés dans des schémas rigides qui
l'ont fait une supposition concernant
mon identité sans me demander mon avis
et qu'ils se sont trompés
alors et si on arrêtait d'avoir peur de
bouger les dents et si on s'offrait de
la liberté les premières barrières
ce sont celles que l'on se met tout seul
ton fils ton il risque quoi si tu lui
offrait une poupée de devenir un bon
papa alors bougez journaux code bons
journaux code est littéralement pour mes
confrères et consorts informaticienne
bouger le code de vos logiciels vous
avez un grand pouvoir de simplification
ma vie et un grand pouvoir implique de
grandes responsabilités
de quoi avons nous peur repensons nos
habitudes nos automatismes remettant en
question le système
sortons de nos carcans on simplifiera
mais grandement la vie de toutes les
personnes qui ne rentrent pas dans le
cadre binaire du sexe et du genre
bien sûr on facilitera aussi l'année
tout le monde faisons le pour moi pour
vous même pour les membres de notre
famille pour nos amis nos collègues et à
l'armée mais quelle chance
extraordinaire on pourrait souffrir la
chance de rencontrer toute la diversité
de ses identités hors norme
toutes ces énergies qui ne demande qu'à
s'épanouir autour de nous si on s'est
vraiment compté jusqu'à plus que mille
envisager qu'il existe plus de deux
cases
je nous fais confiance je sais que c'est
à notre portée